well let's get the very latest from Gaza
yumna elide is joining us from Gaza
right now so yumna tell us more about
the latest situation uh are Rockets
still being
fired Rockets are still being fired very
intensely from the Gaza Strip we've also
seen more and more videos and pictures
come from the Palestinian Fighters that
have infiltrated into the Israeli towns
uh uh we've seen uh Fighters taking over
Eris cross
and uh pictures of Israeli soldiers
there uh being uh killed we've also seen
videos of uh Israeli tank uh set on fire
while Palestinian Fighters around it
celebrating other uh Israeli Vehicles
another one uh one was taken in the
early hours of the morning another one
uh now in Gaza Strip so two armed
vehicles in Gaza uh taken by from by the
Palestinian fire Fighters uh We've also
recently just received a video showing a
very short video of 10 seconds showing
two Israeli soldiers being captured uh
in the hands of the Palestinian Fighters
they say they have captured these two
soldiers alive the video of course shows
the soldiers
alive uh so uh the confrontations are
still taking place inside those Israeli
towns also
uh Israeli fighter Palestinian Fighters
I'm sorry have also said that they have
taken over ashalon prison which is uh
into into very after the Israeli town of
Ashkelon which is about 45 minutes away
from the Edis Crossing in the northern
part of the Gaza Strip so this shows how
far the Palestinian Fighters have
infiltrated into the Israeli towns from
the borders with Gaza right let's talk
about the areas Crossing because it's uh
in the north of Gaza Strip it's has been
under full Israeli control and
presumably very high security uh it's
extraordinary that it's been taken isn't
it it's very extraordinary that this ARA
Crossing could be uh taken over by
Palestinian Fighters but not just the AR
Crossing Nick really all the borders are
are set to be on very high security uh
uh very high uh amount of soldiers uh
deployed on the security fence between
Gaza and Israel it's it's very difficult
uh for or to in to actually uh uh uh uh
anticipate that there could be any kind
of infiltration uh through these borders
to break these borders into the uh
Israeli borders I mean there's always
Whenever there is any kind of
uh uh any kind of movement by the
borders even in the buffer zone which we
call uh in the Palestinian side itself
away about 300 M to to 100 met away from
that separating fence there is always an
attack uh to stop that movement whatever
kind of it so uh there has been a lot of
uh uh young people uh trying to
infiltrate uh unarmed civilians trying
to infiltrate many times and Israeli uh
Army just says that it has arrested them
investigated them and sent them back for
they did not uh hold any kind of threat
uh towards they just approached that
fence so for this kind of operation to
happen in in this amount uh and this
precise uh way is really Beyond
imagination a great surprise not just to
the Israeli side but even to the
residents of Gaza y just give us an idea
of of the sense the mood there in Gaza
amongst residents there given the events
that have unfolded so rapidly
today well as this uh operation has been
uh launched uh already it launch it
started in the very early hours of this
day Saturday uh everything was already
uh closed all shops were already uh
closed they hadn't yet opened uh but uh
uh now uh areas or neighborhoods have
instructed their uh local markets local
shops and supermarkets to open so that
people can get their uh necessities and
Food Supplies quickly because of what uh
could be happening in the next uh coming
hours and the Israeli response on these
uh attacks or these uh Rockets being
launched from Gaza now uh uh as for the
people uh people here in Gaza have
already been living under a stifling
Israeli blockade for the past 17 years
uh the sense is a common sense of fear
and and great worry because again we're
talking about 2.3 million people living
in 365 kilom squar which means buildings
adjacent to one another homes adjacent
to one another uh very uh overcrowded
Refugee care camps with thousands
hundreds of thousands of people in some
refugee camps which means that every air
strike or every targeting means that the
entire neighborhood or the entire uh
Place surrounding that place targeted is
into uh or subjected to a destruction as
well people here in Gaza also because
car on yes
Nick uh because of the borders the ARs
Crossing which only uh uh allows
humanitarian cases and uh and uh workers
to cross into the occupied West Bank is
now uh totally closed while the ra
Crossing uh into Egypt is also closed it
means that people here in Gaza are just
uh uh not able to leave the Gaza Strip
at any time uh in in in in most cases
they were not not allowed but now as we
are witnessing the beginning of a war it
makes or puts great pressure on the
civilians that they have to stay in
their homes and just witness this war y
we'll leave it there for the moment
thanks very much indeed y I'll SED we
can hear Rockets still being fired out
of Gaza across the border y thanks very
much indeed for the time being excuse me
Let's cross down to Rob Reynolds who's
live for us in occupied East Jerusalem
Rob what's happening there
well it's been quiet for the last little
bit here there haven't been any more
rockets in the sky that we could see and
no more um Sirens going off uh but uh
Israeli media is reporting that now at
least five Israelis have been killed in
the rocket barrage from Gaza uh that's
up from one uh earlier in the day they
say that uh Rockets have impacted in Tel
Aviv uh and in other cities in the
southern part of Israel uh this all
again uh have to emphasize coming as a
total shock to Israeli uh citizens and
to the Israeli government and especially
to Israeli
intelligence uh that this uh strike uh B
from Gaza on a scale such as this could
take place without any warning uh almost
almost 50 years to the exact day of the
1973 October war that uh uh also took
Israel completely by surprise and led to
uh many many Israeli Army casualties uh
again uh here in Jerusalem things appear
to be calm uh at least at the moment in
terms of uh any fighting any rocket
barges or any incursions nothing like
that here the uh prime minister bet uh
Benjamin Netanyahu and his uh government
and defense uh officials uh and
intelligence officials are meeting uh
trying to uh establish what to do next
we have heard that the Israeli Army has
shell some areas of Gaza again there are
as we've been pointing out throughout
the morning uh apparently some uh
Israeli soldiers uh taken captive by
these armed incursions from Gaza we've
seen pictures of them on social media
excuse me they have been taken back into
uh Gaza so so they are uh their status
is unknown at the moment so obviously
that'll be a factor in the Israeli
Army's uh decision where and when to
strike they don't want to uh hurt their
own people if that's avoidable in any
wayt if I just jump in there full scale
response in the coming hours yeah this
development of Israeli soldiers being
taken prisoner really does present a
different kind of dynamic to the usual
scenario when these escalations
happen yes it does that's it's rare that
Israeli soldiers are are are captured
and it shows again how extraordinary
this operation is out of Gaza the
paragliders the armed squads of men
moving through the streets of stot which
is the city sort of closest to God of
the Israeli city uh we see pictures of
them uh in vehicles and on foot moving
uh apparently quite calmly and in a
disciplined manner uh through the
streets um I think we are hearing some
sens just
now yes somewhat distant Samir can you
see any uh any contrails in the sky
can't see in the sky any no nothing in
the sky at the moment so my comments
about things being calm here were
apparently premature or at least uh not
not entirely uh up to dat but uh getting
back to the idea of U of captives yes
indeed there was an Israeli soldier
captured on the border with uh Lebanon
some years ago whose fate ripped the
entire nation uh and uh led to many many
uh months and years of negotiations
finally into a a okay we're seeing
two seems like two
contrails in the sky I'm also
seeing a uh puff of smoke that indicates
that a rocket has been
intercepted um you can
hear sirens in the
[Applause]
distance I'd also point out that many of
the streets uh and Roads and highways
leading into Jerusalem and leading
towards the southern part of Israel have
been closed as the uh Army has declared
a state of War
alert um so we don't know what's
happening with this particular
missile uh are we seeing another one
yeah yeah yeah where is
it uh this L yeah
yeah so
Jerusalem still under attack from Gaza
the missiles have traveled this far yes
I can see the the contrails now uh to to
Really terrify the people who are living
here and getting back to that idea of
the uh Soldier uh who's been taken
captive I've seen videos of several
soldiers uh who've been taken captive
today um they seem to be uh not severely
injured um one soldier uh on video
seemed to be either very severely
injured or
dead and um that's going to be something
we'll we'll hear more about but at the
moment we're waiting for the Israeli
government to announce its response and
begin its response in retaliation on
Gaza and perhaps elsewhere back to you